foreign
[Music]
[Applause]
the fox big noon kickoff it'll be the
big noon kickoff the gang is in Iowa
City Iowa will host number four ranked
Michigan on saturday a rematch of the
2021 Big Ten championship game part of
the gang there is Matt leiner the former
NFL quarterback Heisman Trophy winner
how's morale Matt
morale's good I'm good I you know flight
canceled last night got stuck in
Minneapolis just got to uh to Iowa City
damn but I'm doing good man I'm I'm
happy to be on with you and I also I
have I have before we start I got a bone
I got a buddy has got a bone to pick
with you oh okay my my my host Rob Stone
yeah I think I yeah I think you might
have went after him a little bit a
couple weeks ago he told me to he told
me to tell you what's the deal man well
he does have he does have my number and
he did text me and he said I hear you oh
he said yeah he said he lost his number
no no he said he lost his number nope he
uh he texted me and he said I hear
you're coming after me and I go yep I
guess I did and that that's it I you
know it's I'm not afraid if you're
afraid by a dog I just said you had
Urban Meyer there in Nebraska
press him a little bit on Coach are you
interested in Nebraska
would you be interested in Nebraska so
that's all as a host on host crime
that's all that is Matt
I'm I'm with you listen I the it was
interesting because you know I we we are
very well aware of some of the fan bases
who are going to uh make it difficult
for urban yeah in particular last week
um but I'll tell you what Nebraska I
mean those fans I mean they there were
shirts they were chants from the from
the minute we started that show we won
Urban and it was it was actually it was
actually pretty funny
um but but I can tell you now Dan that
he's got no interest in that job that's
for sure why
yeah
I think he's done
um you know I think he's done
um this is my opinion we we we've talked
we've we've talked even before he took
the Jacksonville Job
um last year and and he really you know
he really confided and Brady Quinn and
myself I know Brady is a guest of the
show often and we we talked about just
the NFL gig and and obviously it didn't
work out for him and we know that the
year that he had and the difficulties
and the challenges but
um I don't know I just think I just
think it was kind of a last kind of a
last try to see if he could do it at the
NFL level and
um I will say I know he loves this job
being on TV we got a great group of guys
um I think he's he uh you know he has
the trust of all of us you know I think
he just feels feels a different way but
I mean you never say never you know well
I wonder you know Steve Spurrier failed
miserably in Washington and then went
back and coached at South Carolina
I just thought and I was told if there's
an opening at Arizona State that would
be a smarter move for urban because you
could kind of go in there and if the
Pac-12 still exists
USC's out of there UCLA's out of there
maybe you could you know get 10 11 wins
there and it felt like that that was a
sleeping giant my source said Arizona
State what do you think I
yeah I mean for anybody I still think
the weather the geographically you're
close to California Texas on the other
side
um and the way with college football
expansion and there's actually it's an
interesting because USC and UCLA are
leaving and I'm sure they're not the
only ones when it's all said and done
but there's a real path now with
expansion for for a pactful champion to
get in and it's almost the path is a lot
easier so you know it's kind of schools
like Oregon and Washington were
obviously you know on the up and up a
school like Arizona State I mean gosh we
had our battles with them that you know
Dennis Erickson was great there he Todd
Graham won 10 games there per year you
can recruit there there's good players
in Arizona too in the state got Hamilton
High Chandler High I mean I lived there
for four years it was pretty good high
school football so
um I'm not sure I don't know if it's a
sleeping giant but I do think it's a
it's a place where you could turn around
and you can be competitive and you can
win in particular with the path now to
the playoff in the future
you got Michigan and you got Iowa feels
like Iowa every year has one of those
wins where you go oh man Kirk ference he
can still coach
uh is that this game on Saturday it's
gosh I'll tell you what it is
it's really difficult to watch them on
film especially their offense I mean I
don't need to tell you this but it's
it's a rock fight every time they're on
the offensive side of the ball and it's
it's it's but it but it's it's you know
what I respect coach Prince is great
he's a great man he's a great coach he's
legendary he just doesn't care like he
we always joke in production means we're
just like they will win seven to three
and they won't give a damn like like
that's a great game guys we'll go you
know next you know it's just how they
are and it's so different I'll tell you
what this this team it's it's it's the
same thing as you expect they're punner
Tori Taylor is a stud and I know hunting
and special teams don't get a lot of
play but he's a he has a huge impact for
this team and should this weekend
um their defense is really really good
like that defense is legit every year uh
they they give Ohio State fits I mean
they're um obviously they struggled last
year in this in the big fin championship
game but it I think it'll be a really
good game I don't know what the line is
I think it might be 10 or 10 is it 10
10. yeah I think it's it's going to be a
low scoring game I I really believe that
I don't know if I will can generate
enough points but that defense will keep
them in the game but it's uh yeah it's
uh it's painful to watch at times
name image and likeness is all you know
always something that's there for these
schools and it feels like you know the
bigger the school the more riches the
more opportunities for everybody but if
name image and likeness was around when
you guys were at USC could you have kept
everybody together at USC
um and maybe another year I don't know
and and not to get into Reggie Bush and
his Heisman as much as just you guys
were rock stars there and but I I wonder
what that would have done to that team
given the fact that there could have
been some you know great monetary gains
for you
yeah I mean it was it's a question I get
asked a lot now that nil is legal um I I
stayed all five years so I I would have
been forced out um obviously
um but yeah I just think you know Pete
had such a we had such a great run I
mean gosh the the from recruiting
International recruiting winning and
obviously you know Reggie Reggie had you
know his deal and that that setback USC
for for a handful of years just just how
it was handled how NCAA handled it and
clearly Reggie is still feeling feeling
the repercussions of that with the
Heisman and all that stuff
um but yeah I mean I look USC is is
I mean it's La I mean it's La the market
and and now I mean you could fast
forward it to those years but you fast
forward to now what Lincoln Riley has a
chance to do and the resources he's
going to have and knowing that when USC
is is when they're back and you know
they're not back yet but when they're
winning and it's fun and people are
excited and especially going to the Big
Ten like the exposure that that will
bring them and the competitive value
that that will bring to to that car to
that school
I'm telling you well at USC is is primed
to really kind of elevate themselves
back into what we were uh you know 20
years ago nil I mean I can't even
imagine I mean I could ask all the time
I got well how much money would you have
made look I stayed in college to stay in
college but gosh if I was a sophomore
junior I probably would have stayed in
college to make the amount of money that
I could have made for sure who's the
person who showed up at practice or on
the sidelines and you went oh my God
such and such is here watching
you know we had it's so funny I was
actually at USC practice
um
last week I I did a sit down with Caleb
Williams this past week so I was at the
tail end and I was talking to a couple
of security guards and
when we were there there would Pete had
open practices he did he you know every
once in a while be okay Friday or
whatever it was he would close the
practice but you know Monday Tuesday
Wednesday Tuesday Wednesday Thursday
whatever it was we'd have three thousand
we'd have legit three thousand people at
practice and it started getting a little
a little dicey when you know agents and
at that time there started to be you
know marketing guys showing up and
that's when I know Pete was a little
like okay we gotta slow this down a
little bit because you started you know
those types of people were showing up
but
um to answer your question I mean gosh
we had I mean you know the stories I
mean Will Ferrell came out all the time
um Snoop Dogg came out all the time
um Jerry Bruckheimer was in our locker
room like weekly I mean people he was
always he was the USC guy you know he's
in our locker room I mean it just was it
was I've said this before and I might
have said this on the show but like it
just was normal it really was it was
like it was normal it was every day for
us it was every day was thousands of
people
uh celebrities were there the sidelines
were packed with people we
Pete embraced it because he knew what
that did for USC recruiting all those he
was not stupid and but we also like we
also handle their business I tell
everybody I'm like listen you you could
you could paint this picture of how we
were and we partied which we didn't but
we partied every night like it didn't
matter we showed up and we we kicked
everyone's butt for pretty much for a
long time except a couple teams you know
so we always handled our business
I think he had a concussion against
Arizona State does that sound right
um yeah
I don't know what you thought when you
watched two on Sunday and what what you
saw last night but from personal
experience uh what can you relate to
those situations
well first gosh just scary uh really
really scary and we know I mean
concussions are nothing to play around
with and and to uh especially gosh just
the the you know this is you know the
injury history you know with the hip a
couple years ago and then
um concussions first I just hope he's
okay I haven't I've been kind of
following the reports I know he got
released from the hospital and everybody
was kind of up in arms why is he being
released so early again I'm not a doctor
um and every and and
I've had a significant concussion
against Arizona State where I was
literally I was stayed in the game
because then there wasn't protocol and I
wasn't coming out and you know that I
mean as an athlete you're not coming out
unless you absolutely just can't perform
um I remember just a little bit off top
I remember
um it was a run play and I went to the
opposite side and I got sacked like an
eight yard loss and Pete was like are
you good and I said yeah I'm good I'm
good and then it I I ended up getting my
bearings and I've been okay but that was
then you know this is a different world
now and
I well seeing the hit from from the
Bills game uh clearly he was concussed
um to what extent you know that's that's
something that doctors evaluate and
that's something that uh two only feels
I I would I just would say this and
again I I'm I'm like there's there's a
there's a process and there's layers to
concussion protocol
and I can't imagine
um the Dolphins didn't follow that
Sunday I I don't know again it's just
speculation and I could be wrong but I
just can't imagine that they didn't go
through the layers of the team doctor
the third party doctors the trainers and
all of that in order for him to get
cleared to play
um but that being said last night was
really scary uh to see him and obviously
the the fingers and that that shot is
still is sketched in my mind I hope he's
okay I'm I'm sure there I know there's
gonna be an investigation all those
things so uh but from personal
experience it's scary
um I've played with one I've had the
lasting effects of one for for months
after after a season
um it's nothing to play around with and
I hope he he's okay and I hope that
they they just do their due diligence
and make sure that when he's okay like
he's cleared the play and he's he's good
to go but it was scary man last night
he's Matt Leinart Fox big noon kickoff
Michigan and Iowa what are you doing
with uh Hall of goats
yeah so uh it's been a fun a fun little
project a big project for me this year
with nio I got approached by a former
teammate of mine Greg Carlson uh
actually part of those USC teams uh he
was building he's he's a kind of the
blockchain web three this whole crypto
that he's uh kind of a tech background
and really kind of dove into this the
last couple of years we are currently
building a web 3 blockchain college
football video game uh that will serve
our our serve Nils for college football
players
um think kind of the old school you know
NFL Blitz the arcade style NBA Jam where
it's fun and a lot of you know taunting
and just fun you know Fun Arcade style
so we're in development for that
currently
um we're signing current players to nil
deals currently uh we have some
legendary former players on board and
um the game will launch next year so we
got a while but uh you'll see some some
some drops coming out this fall with
some of our current players and some
trailers and all that so it felt like a
a real natural way for me to sort of
get my hands involved in nil and do it
in a way where I know that that I can
help these players make money and do it
in a right way and do it in a fun way
um as you know it's it's it's a wild
business right now and there's a lot of
gray area and there's a lot of there's a
lot of good people there's a lot of bad
people and I lived it um and uh I was
obviously a part as you mentioned a part
of the teams that probably could have
really benefited off of it so uh it's
been fun it's been a lot of fun to be a
part of this kind of on that side
clearly the big new stuff is awesome man
you know I'm just trying to just same
busy Dan you know just doing a lot of
stuff uh tell Rob Stone to stop being
soft okay you know he he is man he's
he's soft as they come maybe just shoot
him a text you know I think he feels
left out
um shoot him a text and uh I'll whoop
him into shape this weekend no no I'll
when I go to commercial break I'll send
him a text to say got liner to do your
dirty work here you're soft
I was texting I was texting this morning
um with your producer and I'm just like
I I he was like yeah he came after me a
couple weeks ago you know all fun and
games I'm like all right I'll give you a
shout out man we'll talk a little smack
about you buddy it wasn't fun and games
on my part Matt I'm trying to teach I'm
the Next Generation how to do the job I
got Urban Meyer right there they're
Channing for Urban Meyer Urban are you
interested in Nebraska
that's all that's what this is all about
he he needs to be kept in line man so
I'm happy you did that he's soft he's
soft and don't make me fly to Iowa City
because I'll do that if it if I gotta
listen
he he played uh I might get in trouble
he says he's soccer you know I played
soccer you know I'm like well you know
he's a little he's a little soft so yeah
he is I think he was a yell leader for
the football team
I think I think he he had you know like
a sweater white pants and he would yell
yeah that's what Rob Stone funny thing
is the funny thing is I can totally
visualize that yeah yeah he's a he's a
typical pretty boy yeah absolutely but
you can tune into the fox noon kickoff
and you can see how soft Rob stone is
when he hosts that show
uh Matt good to have you back thank you
buddy thanks Dan thanks for having me
man appreciate it that's Matt liner
Fox's big noon see Rob Stone you want
somebody to Do Your Dirty Work
be careful what you ask for
want to play with fire scarecrow you'll
go to Iowa City I will go to Iowa City
right after this show if I need to
call out Rob stone and you ask Irvine
what about Arizona State yeah you want
Arizona to say yeah what about Nebraska
coach